(audience applauds)
Welcome back to Drew's News.
Ross, as a true connoisseur of reality television.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I need your take on this.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Okay, so HelloGiggles talked to experts
to break down exactly why people are on
the reality TV fever.
And they had different takes.
Some said it's because they were so busy
and so disconnected from people in their real lives,
they just wanted to hang out
with a bunch of people for a sense of connection.
Other experts said more about the pure fun
of living vicariously through other people,
going through their love affairs,
and you know, all sorts of life stuff,
in the safety and comfort from their own sweatpants.
Sounds like a risk reward, if you ask me.
Sure.
Now what is your favorite reality television show?
I've talked about it here,
I'll talk about it anywhere,
but I can teach a PHD course in "90 Day Fiance."
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Anybody else? Yes?
Welly and I, we get home,
and you know, we make a little dinner and we watch it.
And we have opinions about it.
I mean, when you watch reality TV shows,
you fall in love with the people,
you invest in the people.
And that's what I do, I actually care about their happiness,
and I know, I know, I know.
Oh no, no.
I mean, to acknowledge the countless hours
that you've spent watching "90 Day Fiance,"
I wanted to give you a little surprise.
Two surprises, actually.
It's a package deal.
No.
Please welcome to the desk,
"90 Day Fiance" stars Darcey and Stacey Silva.
No!
(audience applauds)
Oh my God, shut up!
(upbeat music)
I can't. You know what you're doing to me?
Hello!
Get over here.
Oh my God! Okay.
Come here, sit.
Oh my God, Drew.
Drew!
Hello!
Nice to meet you.
How are you?
I can't even.
Thank you for having us.
Do you know how much I love you?
Now who's who?
Who's Stacey and who's Darcey?
I always have a problem.
Darcey.
Darcey!
Stacey.
Ross and Drew, hi!
Hi!
(audience applauds)
Okay.
I know so much about you.
I cannot believe this is happening
and you guys kept this a surprise from me.
But I have spent so much time with you,
and I hope that's not creepy.
No, not at all.
Not at all.
Oh, wow.
We've watched you fall in and out of love on "90 Day,"
and then you guys got your own spinoff show,
and we have seen love blossom
and love wilt.
Where are we now in terms of our love story?
How are we doing?
Well, for me, I have some new breaking news.
I'm no longer with Georgi.
Ooh!
Yeah, got re-engaged in the summer.
But it just didn't work out
and I felt like I needed to stand in my power
and just love me more, and you know.
I feel much happier, I feel free.
Yeah, good, I'm glad you're taking care of you.
The right one's out there somewhere.
Yes!
Are you ready?
Yeah, you know.
Single, ready to mingle.
Hey, you hear that audience?
(audience applauds)
Single, ready to mingle.
And what about you?
What's going on with your love life?
Still married with Florian.
Seven years together
and obviously, we met way before any TV show.
And you know, we're good.
Can I tell you,
I don't know if you can feel the energy.
I'm just looking at you.
I'm so happy.
I've spent so many hours in bed with you.
(audience laughs)
It's the first time I've ever said that to two women.
But I just have to say, you know,
you share your life, you know.
And so just thank you for opening your life,
because I have been invested for a very, very long time.
Thank you.
Thank you for all your love and support.
And thank you for surprising me!
Yeah!
We're so gracious.
(audience applauds)
Also.
You guys have a new show
that premieres tonight.
Can we talk about that really quickly?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Okay, so "Darcey and Stacey Tell All."
There's a special, and we actually have a clip.
Ready? Roll it.
Oh my God, we have a clip.
Do you think Georgi's gonna show up, Darc?
Georgi's not gonna come today.
So you know, I'm angry.
Hey, babe.
I don't wanna be there
dealing with a lot of people
with their (bleep).
I don't like any man talking to my daughters like that.
Any man.
(audience applauds)
Oh my God, I'm riveted.
Goosebumps.
Yeah.
How do you guys feel about this new show?
It's really gonna tell a lot and show a lot.
And you know, Stacey and I always like,
come from an authentic place.
And you'll see a lot of truths come out.
And the fact that you know, my ex didn't show
was just another reason why I just knew in my gut,
like, once it left my head,
like, my body followed.
I just, you know, hit my limit
and I had to say goodbye.
But it was a great experience.
I feel like it was healing for us.
It was very healing.
It is, it is.
But I'm just thinking about
what you need on the next season.
I think it's a sassy gay friend
that you can go to happy hour with every episode.
(audience laughs)
I'm just throwing it out there that if,
if you need anybody.
Hey, put us on speed dial.
Well, thank you Darcey and Stacey Silva
and "The Darcey and Stacey Tell All Special"
airs tonight on TLC.
And we're so honored to be talking about it.
And thank you so much.
You really have brought so much joy to Rossy's life.
And it's...
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Can I give you a hug now?
We'll be right back.
Thank you for surprising me!
(upbeat music)